I'm still not completely clear on why
you don't catch fire in the daylight.
I am half-human.
My mother's name was Lisa,
and she was a mortal.
I would very much like to hear the story
of how that happened.
She actually showed up at his front door.
She found the castle
and banged on the front door
with the pommel of her knife.
She sounds interesting.
Oh, she was remarkable.
She beat on the door
until my father let her in
and demanded
he teach her how to be a doctor.
Wait, Dracula taught a human woman
how to be a doctor?
What was first, bloodletting?
God, you still think you're funny.
-My father...
-Dracula.
...is a man of science,
a philosopher, a scholar,
and knows things our society
have forgotten three times over.
Do you still not understand
the enormity of what we're doing?
He's gone mad and from that,
there is no recovering him.
-Shame.
-It's a tragedy.
He's a repository
of centuries of learning.
He could have changed the world.
He might have if Mother hadn't died.
She'd sent him out into the world.
That's why he wasn't there
when the bishops took her.
She sent him away?
She sent him to travel.
To learn the state of the world,
true nature of humans, how they live.
She was turning him.
Imagine if he could have aimed
all that knowledge at improving lives.
If the religious inquisition hadn't proved
his worst instincts about humans.
And now he's going to use her death
as an excuse to destroy the world.
Oh, the world will still be here, Belmont.
Trees will still grow,
birds will still sing,
animals will still hump away
in the undergrowth. But you won't be here.
And you won't be here.
None of you.
The sun will still set,
but you will not see it rise.
There will only be Dracula,
and his war council,
and the hordes of the night.
He writes in great books, you know.
He hews the covers himself from oak
and wraps them in the preserved skin
of the people he hated most.
He writes plans. I've seen them.
Ideas for darkening clouds
and making them as permanent in the air
as the frost of the north.
Strange flying machines that pull shrouds
across the sky to block out the sun.
Imagine it.
A world without humans
under endless invented night.
And Dracula in his castle,
his revenge so complete
there is nothing left to do
but look out over a world
without art or memory or laughter
and know that he did his work well.
That he did it all for love.
-You hear that?
-Animals humping in the undergrowth.
Wait, no.
Which is the nearest town?
Is it still Gresit?
Arges is closer to us.